you are about to enjoy a free preview of
the disney and pixar film
[Music]
lucca
[Music]
do we really need to fish near the
island
you worry too much i don't know what if
the old stories are true
oh come on jacob you really believe we
see monsters
so many strange things have been seen in
these waters they're all just
stories tall tastes to keep us away from
a great fishing spot
but tommaso you're fine
ah that's more like it
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
what is that
[Music]
you missed let's go before it comes back
for us
i told you they were real oh what a
monster
[Music]
horrifying
no no no mom's gonna kill me
catalina wait
oh good morning mr branzino and also i'm
sorry
[Music]
hi luca
[Music]
excuse me ma'am have you yes
giuseppe get back here you want to run
off like your buddy and rico well
because i've got news for you he's
either dead or he's
out there somewhere seeing the world
but he's probably dead okay
that's everyone mona lisa why are you
smiling
anyone else in there
giuseppe what did we just talk about
ah just happy all right
let's head out
[Music]
hello good morning
hi this is
good morning
[Music]
okay all clear
[Music]
let me know if you need anything
anyone no
[Music]
okay
she's that bad
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
uh
[Music]
land monsters everybody under the rock
[Music]
luca lunch is
[Music]
they're two minutes late was there a
boat uh huh did you hide yes mom
because if they catch even a glimpse of
you you think they come around to meet
new friends
ah don't make small talk no they're here
to do
murders so i'm just making sure you know
thanks mom when i was
a kid we'd go weeks without seeing a
boat and let me tell you they did not
have motors just a
sweaty land monster with the paddle hi
grandma
hey bubble hi dad luka look at pinkie
pie
she's molting oh it's magnificent
now here's a champion show crab if i
ever saw one
oh nice don't look her in the eye sorry
but don't apologize
she can sense weakness oh
come he luca come on we better beat
those branzinos at the crab show this
year
everyone thinks bianca branzie knows so
great with her prize-winning crabs an
amazing dolphin impression
please anyone can do that
right i don't know why dolphins even
sound like that you know why don't they
just talk
luca huh what's on your mind i i
i will i was just wondering
where do boats come from the land
monster town
just above the surface i beat a guy at
cards there once
mom what are you doing he's old enough
to hear about
it you've been to the surface and and
done the change no not
the end shut it down i was just curious
yeah well the curious fish gets caught
we do not talk think discuss contemplate
or go
anywhere near the surface got it yes mom
here now let's get back to work
hey look me in the eye
you know i love you right i know mom
we're a little worried about him right
no thanks
i'm full
[Music]
huh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
see what happens next order the entire
movie disney and pixar's luca
now available